mais d'abord avec gaspard flamand voici
le zoom de notre baromètre au doxa
mascaret il est consacré à jean luc
mélenchon
le dernier baromètre au doxa mascaret la
firme nous sommes dans un moment
mélenchon à douze jours du premier tour
de l'élection présidentielle le leader
de la france insoumise voit sa cote de
popularité grimper à 33% au plus haut
depuis novembre 2017 il se voit comme la
seule alternative entre les deux
candidats en tête des sondages
monsieur macron c'est le programme
économique de madame le pen plus classe
madame le pen le programme économique de
maquereaux plus que mépris de race
si l'on se concentre sur les
sympathisants de gauche et d'extrême
gauche le député insoumis fait course en
tête avec 60% d'adhésion une progression
de 4 points en un mois bien devant ses
autres concurrents à gauche yannick
jadot fabien roussel et anne hidalgo
si la dynamique jean luc mélenchon est
réelle elle est aussi à nuancer une
majorité des français 57% vote aurait
pour lui par défaut car il est le moins
éloignées de leur valeur ou parce qu'il
représente le vote utile qui permettrait
à la gauche de l'emporter une position
non partagé par la porte parole de
yannick jadot ce que je dis c'est qu'il
ya des différences majeures
entre
jean luc mélenchon et les positions
qu'il prend sur les énergies fossiles
sur poutine sur le fait d'heureux refusé
de le qualifier de dictateur et la
position qui est celle des écologistes
de plus même si elle s'améliore l'image
du leader un souvenir est très mauvaise
deux tiers des français déclarent avoir
une mauvaise opinion de lui on lui
reproche principalement son impulsivité
son agressivité et son populisme le
prochain grand meeting de jean luc
mélenchon est prévu dimanche à toulouse
à une semaine du premier tour
et on tire donc les leçons de ce
baromètre de mars avec mes invités
bérengère bonté bonsoir vous êtes
journaliste auteur du livre le sioux aux
éditions de l'archipel gaël sliman le
président et cofondateur de doxa bonsoir
bonsoir gaël mathieu soupière experts
associés auprès de la fondation jean
jaurès bon soin ou publier coauteur avec
damien fleurot de l'assemblée la flambée
on va le dire dans leur taux tulliste
c'est chez plon et lætitia commença en
soir laetitia éditorialiste politique à
mes côtés comme chaque semaine dans
cette dans cette émission
gaël sliman je commence avec vous au
doxa mascaret donc sur nos partenaires
avec lcp la presse régionale depuis le
mois de septembre chaque mois on a
vraiment consacré du temps analysé
ensemble et les grandes tendances et à
chaque fois il y avait un gros plan sur
une personnalité jean luc mélenchon dont
convient de voir le sujet de gaspard
mais c'est quoi son socle de popularité
en quelque sorte le sujet était vraiment
très bien fait parce qu'il résume tout
c'est à dire que c'est du mélange qu'on
n'aimerait pas mais c'est dû en même
temps c est incontestablement nous
sommes dans un moment mélenchon et vous
avez raison de rappeler thomas on suit
depuis des mois les choses ouais et même
depuis des années sur le baromètre
politique donc il ya bien un moment
mélenchon vous verrez les courbes sur
nos graphiques on le voit monter 33 %
des gens ont une bonne opinion de lui
veut dire aussi que les deux tiers en
une mauvaise mais on va le laisser pour
plus tard 33 des gens pour cent des gens
ont une bonne opinion de lui sa cote
d'adhésion flandre et c'était très bien
rappelé dans vos dents les slides qui
était à l'écran là pour le coup il ya
plus de matches à gauche plus aucun
match à gauche auprès des sympathisants
de gauche dans leur ensemble quand on
prend tous les sympathisants de gauche
ps écologistes extrême gauche etc il
écrase totalement la concurrence doit
sans voile on le voit le 60% à 10 400
plus qu'à toi mais on a vu un an dans le
monde les chiffres présentés tout à
l'heure il ya 20 points 30 points
d'avancé sur les audi fait quasiment le
double d'anne hidalgo imaginez le rêve
pour mélenchon se dire s'il ya cinq ans
lui avait dit tu feras le double du
score auprès des sympathisants de gauche
de popularité du candidat officiel du ps
c'était mes associés était merveilleux
le problème c'est que et puis il
améliore aussi ses différents traits
d'image on y reviendra le problème c'est
que on part de très bas qu'il a beaucoup
abîmé son image après la présidentielle
de 2017 où il était déjà monté très haut
piles étaient redescendus
et que fondamentalement ses traits
d'image comme on dit en de manière
complexe reste reste très négatif on y
reviendra en détail sur les traits
d'image voudrais vous entendre bérengère
bond sur sur jean luc mélenchon est ce
qui peut aller plus haut finalement
qu'en 2017 d'après vous savez ravir la
seconde place qui pour l'instant semble
dévolue à marine le pen de l'étude la
d'aujourd'hui de doxa est vraiment
intéressante justement sur 7 sur cette
marge de progression qui con con qu'on
aurait envie de penser importante
puisqu'on le voit progresser et qui en
réalité ne le semble pas l'être pour les
raisons que qui viennent d'être d'être
expliquée pour pour d'autres raisons
peut-être plus annexes mais qui sont par
exemple qu'un gain est un excellent
candidat au parti communiste fabien
roussel qui prend quand même mine de
rien 3 4% pour l'instant et c'est assez
constant même si c'est plutôt c'est un
petit peu repartie à la baisse même
c'est quand même compliqué et puis à ce
et cette exaspération gers et quelqu'un
essaie il reste extrêmement clivant jean
luc mélenchon et énormément de gens à
gauche même si sa cote à gauche
s'améliore et explose et dans les monts
de gens à gauche ne vraiment ne lui
pardonne pas 2017 et on a vu tous les
tous les critères qui sont insignifiants
études alors je vais prendre quelques
quelques traits d'image qu'il ya dans la
légende dans des commentaires sur les
réseaux sociaux oui je n'en doute pas je
les prends d'ailleurs je tiens à
signaler puisque il ya eu quelques
commentaires sur les réseaux sociaux sur
les qui dit bah on est dans le lot
l'égalité des temps de parole temps de
parole et temps d'antenne hier soir on
était sur un premier débat est là vous
faites trop de droite oui bah là on fait
beaucoup de mélenchon va on va
équilibrer sur la quinzaine on a quinze
jours de campagne officielle et on va
faire en sorte d'équilibré temps temps
de parole et et temps d'antenne donc les
traits d'image ils sont effectivement
assez les items négatif ce sont les plus
puissants quoi pas capable de diriger la
france à 70% pas compétent 63% pas
honnête 63% pas convaincant 59% ça c'est
les traits d'image et les traits de
personnalité ça rejoint ce que
ce que disait bérengère à l'instant
impulsif agressif populis secteur il ya
des traits les très positif on les doit
alors il est très en dessous c'est
s'assurer très positif lors en fait
c'est pas compliqué on teste 10 items
oui c'est des batteries de qu'on appelle
de cribles d'imagés c'est souvent
comparables d'un d'une personnalité
politique une autre on l'avait déjà fait
pour eric zemmour il on était à peu près
la plupart d'entre nous ensemble sur ce
plateau et on voyait que c'était très
négatif aussi sévère comtesse 10 items 5
positive choc négatif et on se rend
compte que les gens disent oh oh oui oui
à tous les items négatif et quand on
teste des qualificatifs positif il à
anono il n'est pas du tout par exemple
convaincant il est pas honnête sacoor le
test en positif 1 parce qu'elle n'est
pas complet sans vous qui donnez les
intitulés des items vicens est temps
pour chacun des qualificatifs suivantes
bien douce il s'applique plutôt bien ou
plutôt mal à jean luc mélenchon est en
fait pour faire simple c'est que les
français dans leur ensemble disent que
tous les défauts lui colle
particulièrement bien enfin le
correspond très bien et qu aucune des
qualités ne lui correspond alors ça
s'est posé à tous les français après
quand on va regarder ce que nous disent
les sympathisants de gauche heureusement
pour lui c'est moins mauvais mais comme
le disait bérengère auprès des
sympathisants de gauche même auprès
d'eux un certain nombre de critères sur
l' impulsivité l'agressivité par exemple
lui sont toujours attribués dochia ce
frein qui date de 2017 et de noeuds de
son refus de du côté mauvais joueur
j'appelle pas à voter macro second tour
je boude j'estime que les
présidentielles mais voler ça les gens
n'ont pas digéré les gens de gauche
notamment le deuxième élément c'est la
république c'est moi alors ça ça l'a
vraiment grillé pour auprès de beaucoup
de gens et puis dernier élément il sans
doute que sa progression était encore
plus forte depuis un mois puisque la
personne à gauche en réalité pour les
électeurs de gauche un kit susceptibles
de pouvoir l'emporter ou faire quelque
chose de bien s'il n'y avait pas eu la
guerre en ukraine parce que ça à raviver
une image de poutine au chili qui lui
qui lui étaient affectés dont c'est la
situation pour lui elle est vraiment
ambivalente il progresse mais il ya
peut-être quand même un plafond de verre
qu'il n'avait pas en 2017 mathieu qui
aura déjà dit pas mal de choses sur jean
luc mélenchon mais je suis sûr vous avez
votre grain de sel à apporter peut-être
justement sur eux alors ça permet
d'élargir aux autres je mets guillemet
peut-être petit au fil de cette campagne
présidentielle est ce que finalement il
il souffre on peut dire ça aussi de
marine le pen - de se passer coutinho
fils cas d'eric zemmour par exemple
analyse effectivement au moment de
l'émergence du conflit on a dit que
trois candidats allaient être
disqualifié en tout cas on a anticipé le
fait qu' il allait prendre cher dans les
enquêtes d'opinion en réalité marine le
pen n'a pas dévissé et encore une fois
je marque un distinguo quand même entre
d'un côté jean luc mélenchon et de
l'autre côté marine le pen et eric
zemmour jean luc mélenchon a toujours
exprimé une indulgence vis-à-vis de la
russie on ne doit pas confondre une
indulgence vis-à-vis de la russie avec
une admiration exprimé explicite
vis-à-vis de valdimir poutine s'est pas
tout à fait la même chose quand même il
ya une nuance dans l'opinion alors
marine le pen elle même s'est maintenue
eric zemmour en revanche à a dévissé à
cause de ça si jean luc mélenchon c'est
pour partie maintenu en tout cas c'est
ce que nous on observe dans nos équipes
dans nos études de la fondation au reste
si c'est pour partie maintenu malgré la
crise ukrainienne c'est parce que il a
commencé à monter au moment où
précisément christiane taubira sortait
du jeu et donc il ya eu un effet
christiane taubira qui a joué
essentiellement en faveur de jean-luc
mélenchon néanmoins le score qu'il a
aujourd'hui est effectivement élevé nous
mêmes dans notre panel ipsos on observe
exactement la même dynamique il n'est
pas très loin de marine le pen il est
potentiellement au deuxième très loin
c'est
le comptabilise aujourd'hui à 14 % et
marine le pen à 17 et demi pour cent on
a un panel de 13000 13000 questionné il
fait une marge d'erreur très faible
néanmoins la volatilité de l'électorat
reste encore aujourd'hui extrêmement
forte et encore plus forte à gauche si
la moitié des électeurs de russel
hidalgo et jadot se déporte dans les
prochains jours verts jean luc mélenchon
il est au deuxième tour il est au
deuxième tour et il suffit que eric
zemmour lui même fasse une bonne
séquence pendant les dix prochains jours
prennent un point à marine le pen et et
le jeu de la finale et rejouer et c'est
d'autant plus surprenant pardon je
termine d'un mot alors effectivement en
plus fabien roussel et là il ya cinq ans
il n'y avait pas de concurrence du parti
communiste donc on pourrait imaginer que
jean luc mélenchon serait encore plus
haut en l'absence de fabien roussel et
c'est d'autant plus surprenant que en
termes d'image personnel jean luc
mélenchon a totalement raté son
quinquennat gaël rappelle les
différentes étapes les différents gamin
qu'il a pris mais par ailleurs la france
insoumise elle-même est un parti qui
globalement est passé à côté du
quinquennat il perdu à peu près toutes
les élections intermédiaires toutes les
élections intermédiaires donc on ne
voyait pas que la france insoumise était
une force politique en dynamique
al'approche de la présidentielle
laetitia je pense que jean luc mélenchon
comme anne hidalgo c'est l'illustration
d'une erreur de casting total il n'a pas
laissé la place jean luc mélenchon il a
voulu y aller une troisième fois or il y
avait françois ruffin qui d'ailleurs
l'avait dit face à jean-jacques bourdin
donc ce n'était pas un secret d'alcôve 1
il avait dit s'il faut ramasser le
drapeau je suis là pour le ramasser ou
adrien 4 nages on aurait pu imaginer
d'autres incarnation que jean luc
mélenchon qui partait déjà avec tous ces
handicaps qui étaient listés qui était
connu qui était identifiée par son camp
et par les autres donc il y à une erreur
de stratégie dès le départ et en plus
jean luc mélenchon depuis le début a
toujours refusé d'appeler au
rassemblement de la gauche il a refusé
les primaires il a refusé quelques ce
quelques discussions que ce soit et donc
il arrive in fine et en se présentant
comme le vote efficace alors il dit
efficace à la france a soumis zaba
utiles pour bien se quand même se
démarquer de ségolène royal qui aurait
pu donner un élément de langage on peut
pas quand même faire la filiation
directe mais il y à toutes ces erreurs
qui il me semble pourrait lui coûter
justement une seconde deuxième place qui
aurait pu arriver oui c'est vrai oui
mais mais mais mais quand même moi je
retiens ce que ce que vient de dire
mathieu gaël sliman c'est que il ya il
ya un côté aspirateur à voix de gauche
qui est en train quand même de
fonctionner
depuis plusieurs milliards jours voire
plusieurs semaines un médecin c'est
indiscutable serre que on l'a déjà je
reviens sur ce que disait mathieu mais
on l'a déjà abordé sur ce plateau il y a
c'est existe des électeurs de gauche
révélation il y à des électeurs de
gauche qui n'ont pas disparu et qui est
la partie il en revanche emmanuel macron
alors primo ça existe secundo certains
sont partis chez makro mais pas tous et
ceux qui ne sont pas partis chez makro
sont pas partis chez emmanuel macron
parce qu'ils estiment qu emmanuel macron
ne même pas la politique qu'il
souhaiterait n'est pas de gauche est
trop à droite c'est donc il ya un vivier
ya un potentiel et ça c'est diagnostiqué
depuis des mois et puis mathieu le
disait très justement il y avait un
match qui existait pourquoi pas yannick
jadot yannick jadot il ya un moment il a
son investiture il commence à progresser
dans les sondages et puis il ya un truc
qui va pas ça n'imprime pas il commet
pas jusqu'à sa phrase sur eric zemmour
il ne commet pas de faute majeure mais
il ya un truc qui va pas ça ne prend pas
dans l'opinion anne hidalgo bombe à ces
fonds
fabien roussel connaît cette petite
progression est plutôt bon en com et les
l'électorat de gauche il est orphelin et
dans notre sondage on a quelque chose
qui permet de le mesurer qui est assez
génial il faut pas confondre ça
s'appelle un potentiel de vote et donc
un potentiel de vote ça n'est pas une
intention de vote 1 c on demande aux
gens s'ils pour un candidat donné il
pourrait certainement voté pour lui mais
ils peuvent le dire aussi dans nos dons
s'il pourrait probablement voté pour lui
ou bien s'il ne pourrait pas voulu voter
pour ce candidat et ce potentiel de vote
ça nous permet de mesurer le delta le
club et la majorité sur et si on est
pour exister et deuxième élément ça nous
permet aussi de voir quel électorat ce
candidat pourrait potentiellement
séduire le cas du de mélenchon est
intéressant parce que le potentiel de
mélange de mélenchon et à 12 %
d'électeurs qui je pourrais certainement
voté pour lui mais ils peuvent aussi le
dire d'un autre candidat donc il peut
faire moins de 12 ans et 15 % qu'ils
vous pourrez probablement voter pour lui
c'est possible ça fait 27 au total
marine le pen on a testé en même temps
pour un étalon elle est à 37 donc le
potentiel de voix de mélenchon est
inférieur à celui marine le pen dans les
intentions de vote c'est dans
l'intention de vote ipsos que l'écart
est le plus réduit que ce que reçoit
rappelé mathieu nous on en a pas sortie
depuis une quinzaine de jours donc notre
écart était plus important mais dans les
derniers ya quand même une avance
substantielle pour marine le pen a pour
l'heure et ce qui est intéressant c'est
que mélenchon séduit des électeurs et on
a posé une question qui est intéressante
je vais vous donner le résultat c'est
pourquoi vous pourriez voter pour jean
luc mélenchon pour quelles raisons et ce
qui est avancé avant tout ce sont des
raisons de vote efficace utile appelez
ça comme vous voulez et donc en gros pas
du tout de l'adhésion parce que c'est un
formidable tribun est indéniable mais
tout simplement bas parce que je veux
voter utile nous disent ces
sympathisants souvent de gauche pour
vous permettre à la gauche même pas de
se qualifier mais de peser de ne pas
être totalement ridicule l'espoir de
beaucoup d'électeurs de gauche c'est que
on est un candidat de gauche qui fasse
10 12 13% 14 % un score pas indigne et
l'autre raison c'est parce que c'est le
candidat le moins éloigné mes valeurs
mais ce qu'ils disent c'est parce que
j'adore c'est sa personnalité ou son
programme sont minoritaires ils avaient
connu cette même dynamique en 2010 est
bien plus à risque il était monté
beaucoup plus haut bérengère je pense
qu'il faut qu'on soit quand même assez
prudent sur le sens cette histoire de
vote utile qui va fonctionner à gauche
probablement et c'est vrai que plus on
va s'approcher du nosi de ce premier
tour plus
quelques électeurs de fabien roussel
quelques électeurs de ganic jadot
pourquoi pas de philippe poutou vont se
dire quand même là l'hypothèse de placer
un candidat de gauche au 2e au deuxième
tour est intéressante mais il va aussi
faire l'effet de repoussoir absolu je
vis à vis de l'électorat de droite et je
pense moi que le vote utile à droite en
faveur de marine le pen va va augmenter
proportionnellement alors on est pas on
est fan avant maintenant luc mélenchon
s'est allumé mais pour garder bat pour
conserver cette province est 2e place et
cette place en finale ce qui serait ce
qui vas tu vas dire que cette ces
incertitudes dont on parle et qu'on
essaie de maintenir dans nos débats et
pas artificiellement parce qu'il a
encore beaucoup
si beaucoup de volatilité on le rappelle
à chaque fois ça peut peut-être on
parlera d'abstention dans un instant
vous amener une abstention plus plus
faible que prévu le message gardez aux
arguments sur la possession du bien mais
bien peu plus le volant le réservoir
pour marine le pen il est en réalité
plus important puisque c'est le
réservoir zemmour donc attention à voilà
vote utile contre 28 il alors on est à j
- 12 1 avant le premier tour laetitia
comment les candidats a fait un peu de
stratégie de communication comment
peuvent-ils se démarquer donc pendant
ces deux semaines d'égalité absolue tant
qu'à changer un peu la change aussi leur
stratégie ah oui nathalie arthaud jean
lassalle ont le même temps de parole que
emmanuel macron marine le pen donc oui
ça change bien sûr il faut se démarquer
se distinguer il ya beaucoup de
stratégies qui sont mises en place qui
sont connus qui sont pensés en amont et
puis il ya la stratégie qu'on a vu hier
s'est déployée de la petite phrase la
petite phrase qui va être retenu qui va
imprimer les médias et tourner comme ça
pendant 24 heures c'est celle d'
emmanuel macron qui répondait au macron
assassin entendu lors du meeting d'eric
zemmour au trocadéro écouter ce que dit
le président certains il ya deux
hypothèses la première c'est la dignité
et au 16e qui me semble la plus crédible
si ce n'est pas une surprise la deuxième
c'est la méconnaissance d'une réforme
très importante du quinquennat c'est le
100% santé et maintenant les prothèses
auditives les lunettes et les prothèses
dentaires sont remboursées par la
sécurité
10 millions de françaises et de français
ont eu accès à cela ça fait partie de
mon bilan c'est un bilan social dont je
suis fier et bien vite alors à ce moment
là le candidat malentendants à pouvoir
s'équiper à moindre coût pourquoi cette
efficace parce qu'on croit beau concept
une blague c'est une ironie c'est une
pique contre eric zemmour pourquoi elle
efficace parce qu'elle est reprise
immédiatement et on va demander à nos
positions de réagir donc il a le lead ce
qu'on appelle le litre c'est lui qui
impose ce thème et les autres sont
forcés d'être en réaction et bien sûr on
demande à eric zemmour à plusieurs
reprises je crois qu'il a répandu une
dizaine de fois depuis hier et jusqu'à
ce matin où la question mais encore posé
écouter ce que répond le candidat de
reconquête c'est pas qu'il avait une
bonne raison c'est qu'effectivement il y
a des raisons d'être furieux il y a des
raisons d'être en colère et je voudrais
vous dire quand même autre chose parce
que cette polémique est en même temps
complètement surdimensionné que je suis
mais j'ai été un journaliste pendant 30
ans pendant cette campagne et en
particulier avec ce meeting je comprends
pourquoi les gens détestent les
journalistes tactique archiconnu
surexploitée par donald trump utilisé
par eric zemmour qui fantasment 1 depuis
le début sur donald trump et donc ils
accusent les journalistes c'est la
responsabilité des journalistes la
presse évidemment
les uns et les autres et réagir à la
chronique de laëtitia je n'en doute pas
mais je voudrais conclure sur cette
histoire de 2 d'exposition médiatique là
il ya une fenêtre importante attention
au faux pas c'est aussi ce qu'il faut
évidemment soin de se dire éviter les
pièges bien sûr les faux pas mais en
général les challenger jouent leur
va-tout donc vous maximiser le massif du
risque bien sûr prennent plus de risques
il maximise les occupations sur tous les
espaces il y à la presse il ya surtout
les plateformes internet les réseaux
sociaux donc là ils font vraiment et
sous leur va tout et pour les favoris
comme emmanuel macron on va dire qu'ils
retiennent les chevaux pourquoi thomas
par exemple pour que le meeting emmanuel
macron là samedi soient diffusées par
les télévisions il faut qu'ils ne soient
pas trop présent dans les jours qui
précèdent et donc ses équipes s'était
dit bon on va communiquer le moins
possible pour être quasiment sûr que
toutes les télé retransmettent le
meeting le seul meeting emmanuel macron
et finalement échange de et parce que il
va faire plusieurs médias dont vous
voyez même ce qui est pensé en amont
parfois revu vraiment à l'aune de la
campagne jour le jour alors revenons sur
cette polémique avec vos bérengère bond
ce candidat malentendants vous recevez
vous moi je trouve qu'il y ait que c'est
assez risqué en fait on a et on est déjà
eu le président qui emmerde et les non
vaccinés voilà qui s'en prend voire
indicible alors ok c'est l'humour enfin
le malentendant et tout son petit
dégagement sur sur cette loi santé etc
n'est destiné qu'à cette petite bague
finale
qui grince un mât
moi je trouve qu'il ya une prise de
risque assez importante et que ça peut
être très très mal perçu franchement
d'ailleurs jean luc mélenchon a vraiment
surfer sur cette idée là l'opposition
s'est engouffrée yannick jadot ils ont
tous dit oui stigmatise les handicapés
les malentendants jean luc mélenchon et
hull ayant lui-même et effet étapes sont
son handicap de savoie la de ces
difficultés auditives donc voilà il a
rebondi effectivement là dessus le en
matière de com effectivement on rentre
dans une séquence un peu compliqué et un
peu risqué on est dans une campagne
électorale mme campagne présidentielle
où on se plaint déjà que les débats de
fond et été escamoté d'être passé pour
partie à côté de la campagne
présidentielle si les dix derniers jours
sont essentiellement consacrée
précisément à des tentatives avec buzz
effectivement yannick jadot a tenté de
s'en sortir et d'exister un peu
récemment avec son buzz autour du chef
de service il est revenu en boomerang et
plus récemment un plus récemment dans
dans le bras de fer un peu forcée avec
total voilà mais oui mais on voit bien
que c'est limité en réalité comme un
corps cet argument d'une campagne
escamoté vois ça alors je vais pas être
nombriliste nous c'est vrai qu'on a fait
une de multiples débats sur les
programmes et il ya beaucoup d'autres
médias qui le font tous les jours tous
les jours il ya des gros plans sur tel
thème de campagne comment voilà ce que
disent les candidats vrai ou faux enfin
sur toutes les radios à la télévision
forcément une campagne sur le rocher sur
le fond ya un débat et il ya même un
débat depuis longtemps c'est dire qu'on
n'est pas dans une campagne
présidentielle sans débat il ya eu des
primaires il ya eu des débats il ya eu
un phénomène et moore il ya les médias
se sont fait l'écho de la campagne
depuis des mois et des mois avec souvent
des scores d'audience très élevé on ne
peut pas dire qu'on passe totalement je
suis d'accord à côté de la campagne
ensuite sur les débats de fond quand
même il ya globalement quand même une
forme de lassitude de l'opinion qui
s'exprime non pas seulement vis-à-vis de
la présidentielle alors il ya un intérêt
en recul sur la présidentielle mais il
ya plus globalement un désintérêt de
l'opinion quant à l'actualité c'est très
net c'est à dire que l'intérêt de
l'opinion pour l'actualité a reculé de
dupes de 10 points en 2021 il ya eu une
telle sur actualitté en 2020 avec le co
vide qui a un effet de saturation et de
ce point de vue là la campagne
présidentielle et est une victime
collatérale de ce désintérêt des
français pour l'actualité dans son
ensemble mais juste dernière dimension
le sujet sur lequel on a atterri après
avoir que la question sociale et
environnementale serait prédominante
puis à l'automne avec l'émergence de
zemmour que la question identitaire et
migratoire serait elle-même prédominante
on a finalement atterri sur la question
du pouvoir d'achat sur la question du
pouvoir d'achat
préoccupations écrasante pour l'ensemble
de l'opinion et qui nous cliff pas c'est
une campagne peut-être avec des débats
mais en tout cas sans clivage parce que
le pouvoir d'achat pour le coup c'est un
thème ultra consensuelle au point que le
président macron entrant dans l'arène
devenant candidat a mis sur la table
comme première mesure comme premières
propositions programmatiques la
suppression de la redevance télévisée
comme projet de société on admettra que
c'est un tout petit peu court quand même
donc si une campagne présidentielle ce
sont des projets de société qui
s'affrontent qui permet de cliver
l'opinion et de structurer ensuite
l'action publique pour un quinquennat on
n'y était pas tout à fait quand même
alors on va prendre du temps pour parler
des entre guillemets je mets des
guillemets petits candidats je propose
d'écouter nicolas dupont aignan dray sur
cette polémique autour des propos de du
président candidat
on écoute c'était sur rtl ce matin le
candidat de debout la france je ne suis
pas là pour défendre monsieur macron je
suis là pour qu'on parle de la france et
des français et vous n'avez parlé que de
ça du meeting d'eric zemmour je suis pas
pour y est mort je suis en désaccord
avec l'esprit qui règne dans ses
meetings et on n'entendra pas ça dans
mes meetings mais la seule chose que
vous avez retenu à coeur d'antenne c'est
des polémiques débile pour victimiser ce
présent la réplique en danger remonte à
l'earl attaques contre le journaliste ou
en l'occurrence la journaliste qui pose
la question c'est un classique de danton
dans tous les partis de tous les bords
politiques c'est pas très très nouveau
mais ça rejoint la chronique de laetitia
leur comment ces candidats qui sont
entre 0 et 2%
peuvent exister et ça pose aussi la
question l'inanité à quoi ça sert une
candidature une énième candidature moi
je pense que comme bout en l'occurrence
que cette campagne n'a pas été
inexistante mais ce qui a évidemment
manqué c'est le candidat sortant le
président sortant dont on attendait et
dont l'opinion attendait une
confrontation une confrontation avec les
challengeurs et kiki j'ai revu
les sondages donnent emmanuel macron
largement favori de cette élection
depuis bien longtemps et depuis que les
petits ou moyens candidats sont entrés
dans l'arène donc c'est ça qui manque
est aussi profitent ces sacs à main pour
pousser des propositions fortes et
réussir à les imposer mais monter sur un
ring sans avoir l'adversaire sans avoir
le champion du monde en titre ça ne veut
pas dire que ce sera c'est le gagnant
mais c'est le champion du monde en titre
qu'est ce que vous voulez vous battre
vous battez contre des moulins à vent
alors oui certains fabien roussel a
profité de sa cabriole fabien roussel
qui partait de rien du tout les
communistes n'avaient pas eu de candidat
depuis trois élections lui en a profité
en confiance gaël sliman c'est pas
forcément un focus de votre baromètre
mais quand on voit la campagne de
nathalie arthaud celle de
dép dupont-aignan on a un peu
l'impression de voir la même campagne
que celle des dix 10 à 5 ans donc il ya
un petit effet bis repetita pour tout
cela sur sur l'aspect campagne le
sentiment qui accompagne alors il ya
quand même un douche deux éléments de
réponse tout va sur ce que vous dites
est subjectivement dans nos enquêtes les
français ont l'impression qui a pas eu
de campagne donc que leur perception
c'est que on en a pas beaucoup parlé ils
rejoignent bélanger en dix ans mais en
même temps on aurait bien voulu entendre
le président et en même temps on
comprend que lui ici qui disent je veux
être président jusqu'au bout et puis que
les autres les précédents ont fait comme
lui doit quelques événements qui qui ont
un peu voilà je vais dire justifier le
fait de rentrer et allonger sa campagne
et ya le sentiment que cette élection à
cause des sondages si j'ose dire c'est
moi qui suis fondeur qui le dit que
cette élection est joué d'avancé donc je
ne dis pas moi mais on a beau dire il
ya des indécis les gens polis et puis on
a pris autant au premier tour maintenant
on est trop près de l'échéance pour
qu'il puisse y avoir une grande surprise
sur la qualification d' emmanuel macron
autant il faudra faire des hypothèses de
second tour on en fait déjà il faudra en
faire une fois que l'élection aurait eu
lieu quel effet ça aura en termes
d'abstention qui rit êtes déjà très
forte au premier si on est bien sûr un
duel
macron le pen que feront les électeurs
de gauche on a quelques cents quelques
quelques pistes de d'avant le 1er tour
mais ce sera intéressant de le revoir
donc on ne peut pas dire que l'élection
soit j'ai des avances mais les gens sont
persuadés ils sont persuadés que cette
élection ait joué dans ce cas pas eu de
campagne il n'y a pas d'enjeu il ya un
sentiment un peu désespéré sur un regard
totalement désabusé sur ce qui se passe
et puis il ya des frustrations
objectivement le peuple de droite
parlementaire classique attendait
beaucoup de la candidate et l'air au
mois de décembre elle a flambé dans nos
intentions de vote elle s'est retrouvée
qualifier au second tour face à macro on
était à touche touche à 50/50 donc là il
y avait pour la première fois et puis
patatras voilà ça s'est pas bien passé
pour elle à partir de janvier le peuple
de gauche il espère un candidat il
voulait pas de mélenchon est-ce que
mélenchon il le connaissait déjà donc
quand mélenchon était à 8 % dans les
sondages à l'automne dernier c'était
parce que les gens de gauche non macro
nist qui ne se retrouvait pas dans macro
voulait de quelqu'un d'autre c'eut pu
être la candidate socialiste ça n'a pas
pris le candidat écologiste ça n'a pas
pris
donc ils se sont rabattus ils sont en
train de se rabattre sur mélenchon mais
il ya bien un sentiment d'une élection
qui va se jouer par défaut qui ne fait
pas rêver qui ne fait pas envie et qui
posera question quand même sur la presse
oui évidemment et ça on aura une aura
l'occasion pour parler on va justement
développé détailler un peu cette
question de 2 l'abstention avec fanny
conquis qui peut nous rejoindre sur ce
plateau avec voilà des
hypothèses des initiatives on va dire
pour essayer de sortir de ce désamour
des des électeurs français pour leurs
échéances et leurs élections notamment
ici au sénat eu pas mal de d'initiative
et d'idées oui effectivement un thomas
on rappelle par exemple que le taux
d'abstention a atteint plus de 66 % lors
du premier tour des élections régionales
c'était à l'année dernière alors depuis
plusieurs années en effet un les
sénateurs proposent des pistes pour
favoriser le vote et la participation au
scrutin est une des options et bien
c'est par exemple le vote par
correspondance dans le contexte de la
pandémie plusieurs sénateurs de diverses
couleurs politiques d'ailleurs y était
favorable en novembre 2020 par exemple
sénateurs et l'hérault m xavier
iacovelli s'est emparé du sujet le
président du sénat gérard larcher a lui
aussi avait également appelé à
travailler sur le vote par
correspondance et puis le sénateur
socialiste éric kerrouche avait lui
déposé plusieurs propositions dans ce
sens cependant avec le vote par
correspondance se pose la question de la
sincérité du scrutin en fonction du
moment du vote les électeurs ne serait
alors pas tous soumis aux mêmes
informations et on sait que pendant une
campagne électorale et bien chaque jour
compte un problème auquel eric aux
rouches avait la solution écouter dans
le dispositif que je propose si vous
avez changé d'avis vous pouvez toujours
venir voter en présentiel parce que les
votes par correspondance ne sont pris en
compte qu'à la fin des opérations de
vote donc il ya un moyen de correction
et on rappelle que le vote par
correspondance a existé en france il a
été supprimé en 1975 parce qu'il y avait
des fraudes thomas alors quels sont les
autres pistes proposées par le sénat
alors les sénateurs ont également
réfléchi au vote électronique en
décembre 2020 une mission d'information
présidée par françois noël buffet
président de la commission des lois au
sénat s'est penché sur le sujet du vote
électronique mais après un mois
d'auditions et d'études sur des modèles
étrangers les sénateurs ont conclu qu en
france les conditions matérielles et de
sécurité n'étaient pas réunies pour
permettre ce la mise en place de ce type
de participation pour les scrutins
suivants enfin sachez aussi un cocher
les socialistes il y a eu l'idée
d'instaurer le vote as z'ont en décembre
dernier 1 par exemple groupes
socialistes écologistes et républicains
du sénat avait inscrit à l'ordre du jour
sa proposition de loi pour un nouveau
pacte de citoyenneté avec la jeunesse un
texte qui était portée par la sénatrice
du nord martine filleul et je vous
propose à ce sujet d'écouté patrick
kanner président du groupe socialiste au
sénat sur le vote à 16 ans donc c'était
en décembre dernier au micro comics et
là ce sont les jeunes et les dramatiques
aujourd'hui il y a trois quarts des
jeunes qui sont abstenus aux dernières
élections départementales et régionales
trois quarts est ce qu'on peut se dire
bain puisqu'il ya trois cadavres temps
sur les jeunes donc pas de vote à 16 ans
non au contraire plus les jeunes votent
rapidement précocément avec un
accompagnement effectivement de
citoyenneté est bien plus on en fera des
citoyens sur le long terme alors cette
proposition de loi n'a pas été adopté
par le sénat car la majorité sénatoriale
de droite et contre l'abaissement de
l'âge légal du vote selon les sénateurs
de droite le fait de dissocier droits de
vote et majorité civile peut induire une
confusion et puis par ailleurs pour eux
la population une population plus jeune
et pas forcément disposés à saisir les
gens les enjeux de la vie publique et
institutionnelle selanne augmenterai
donc pas automatiquement le taux de
participation ce qu on dit merci fanni
pour pour tous et d'information mathieu
souquet ça devrait être une réforme
prioritaire du futur ou la future
présidente
oui alors on pointe effectivement les
risque d'abstention alors je regardais
les chiffres pareils dans notre panel
ipsos on observe que y'a 67% des
français qui sont aujourd'hui sûrs
d'aller voter c'est en recul mais de
quelques points seulement par rapport à
ce qu'on observait en 2017 en 2010 est
également c'est dans les tous derniers
jours que les électeurs se sont
réveillés donc on n'est jamais à l'abri
d'un éveil ce qui est sûr c'est que
l'enjeu est moindre cette fois ci il n'y
a pas d'enjeu de nouveautés il faut
admettre que la finale ou en tout cas le
duel le duel à trois puisque on parlait
aussi pour luc mélenchon salaires et
emmanuel macron marine le pen et jean
luc mélenchon se sont entre guillemets
des redoublants ou en tout état cause
des survivants hier qu' on a trois
finalistes potentiels qui était déjà là
en 2017 et non seulement il n'ya pas
l'effet nouveauté mais il ya
effectivement comme le dit leur gueule
il n'y a pas d'enjeu apparemment pas de
suspense parce que les écarts sont assez
fort entre le premier et les numéros 2
et 3 voilà donc ça et pour le coup ça
peut créer une abstention un peu plus
forte encore que d'habitude mais on
pointe souvent l'abstention et la montée
de l'abstention comme l' indice majeur
de la crise démocratique j'envoie un
autre bien plus révélateurs en réalité
depuis
depuis que la vème république existe
aucun président et gouverneur sortant
n'est parvenue à se faire réélire les
français ont à chaque fois votée dégage
east ont à la fois sorti les sortants
alors même que une élection on pouvait
susciter un espoir cinq ans après ou
sept ans après en général le sortant
était balayée oui puisqu'on rappelle il
eu françois mitterrand il y avait une
cohabitation est ce que jacques chirac y
avait une cohésion une nouvelle
démonstration elle ne tient pas mathieu
excusez moi parce que si l'hypothèse 1
emmanuel macron est réélu ça voudrait
dire qu'il n'ya pas de désaffection qui
se met pas de crise alors qu'elle est là
mais alors donc j'allais tuer j'allais y
venir cher laetitia le plus étonnant de
cette campagne présidentielle c'est que
alors que nous sommes convaincus et de
ce point de vue là un certain nombre
d'avis lattès que nous sommes dans une
crise de défiance et une crise
démocratique profonde pour la première
fois dans l'histoire de la vème
république emmanuel macron pourrait être
réélu avec un score au premier tour si
on en croit les sondages qui serait
supérieur à son score de 2017 c'est tout
à fait étonnant alors il aurait pour la
première fois dans l'histoire de la vème
république la longévité le deuxième
mandat dodon dont ses prédécesseurs
n'ont pas réussi à bénéficier il aurait
la légitimité la longévité sans avoir la
confiance la longévité sans la confiance
c'est sans doute extrêmement compliqué
mais c'est compliqué mais quand même
mais angers remonte est ce que si on est
dans un dans une hypothèse encore une
fois il ya beaucoup d'indécis etc etc je
vais pas me répéter si emmanuel macron
et est élu président ce sera le seul de
la vème république a
à le réussir à faire finalement mentir
les statistiques et d'histoire ça ne lui
donnerait pas suffisamment la légitimité
il sera élu
normal qu'on vous dira quand même mal il
sera élu avec 22 mieux 25% du pays
derrière lui ce qui est le lot quand
même aussi un jour un peu salée premier
cétacé mâle cas ça n'a pas toujours été
le cas le relais toujours été le cas
sauf sauf mitterrand en 80 de oui c'est
ça de gaulle pompidou même giscard
mitterrand chez les délais dernier
évidemment les derniers présidents sont
dans ce cas là et ça complique
singulièrement les débuts de mandat
d'ailleurs le allait imposer dans l'est
dans les premiers cent jours des mesures
fortes quand vous allez en g14 un quart
de l'électorat les rangs en adhésion
pleine à sauf erreur de ma part un
mitterrand en 81 ch et 24% au premier
tour et giscard et bien devant et ça ne
m'empêche pas en 81 et ça ne m'empêche
pas de gouverner d'abord le pouvoir mais
pour le coup la suze de gouvernement et
c'est ce qu'affirme manuel macro avec
edouard philippe la sq d'astuces de
gouvernement était d'aller chercher les
charismes et et l'ont alors
qu'aujourd'hui ça commençait à être
compliqué le coût de la droite
l'élargissement à droite il l'a déjà
fait il va continuer et probablement
avec les eric woerth les estrosi etc
mais le ce travail là est déjà fait il
n'empêche qu'il va gouverner avec lui va
peut-être qu'un
gouvernement
alors c'est compliqué à deux éléments
encore une fois dû en même temps de
l'ambivalence ou ce que vous voudrez
tout ce que vous dites sur
les
le manque d' enthousiasme le manque de
les bleus manquent de confiance est vrai
mais raison quand même en tendance
notre baromètre politique du jour il
nous dit quelque chose qui est très
intéressant en un mois la popularité des
manuels mâcon g de cinq points on a beau
26% voilà il ya 46 % en deux mois ça
grimpe de 7 points certes y'a pas loin
d'un français sur deux et comme on est
en france c'est beaucoup dans d'autres
pays ce serait désastreux mais en france
c'est un benchmark en comparaison c'est
incroyable qui dit finalement c'est pas
mal certes cette guerre en ukraine on a
beaucoup dit ça fait grimper emmanuel
macron dans les intentions de vote et
puis parfois en montrant la lune
et c'est l'histoire on se dit ah mais il
a baissé ah oui il est monté à dents
chez certains ce confrère réaliser des
sondages très fréquent il a dépassé les
30 il est retombé sous les 30 m il est
quand même en gros en moyenne dans les
différents instituts
4.5 points au dessus de son niveau de la
présidentielle de la dernière mais aussi
au dessus de son niveau de la garde
avant la guerre en ukraine mais ça c'est
rien ce qui a changé c'est la
réévaluation complète de son bilan et
nous tous les indicateurs ou on évalue
le bilan du gouvernement sur des trucs
qui n'ont rien à voir avec
l'international et la guerre en ukraine
et bien avec ce qui vient de se passer
les gens nous disent le bilan global des
manuels macro il n'est pas si mauvais
que ça donc on a toujours une majorité
de gens qui ne se retrouvent pas dans sa
politique c'est toujours problématique
mais vous l'avez dit et rappelé c'est
pas nouveau pour un président en
revanche grâce à la guerre en ukraine et
avant ça il y avait eu le coc vide bah
finalement y compris l'évaluation
complète du bilan d' emmanuel macron est
moins dramatique moins sévère qu'elle ne
l'était il ya encore deux mois ou trois
mois et on voit sa cote de popularité
chez les sympathisants ps et europe
écologie vérité à 45% et pour les
sympathisants et l'air 56% bérengère
bonté où on voit pas beaucoup edouard
philippe dans cette campagne est ce qui
va sortir cette carte peut-être lors de
son meeting samedi je ne sais pas il
avait dit qu'il était à nice avec
christian estrosi
il m'avait pour connaître
moi j'ai intitulé cette enquête le sioux
moi j'ai sorti ce bouquin et il continue
à faire le sioux c'est à dire qu'
évidemment qu'il est chaque fois qu'on
les interroge
jure mordicus
c'est vrai qu'il soutient président on
peut pas dire qui et qui mouille
énormément la chemise mais bon il est là
certains moments il est en train
d'installer son parti je pense que
l'enjeu du moment c'est de cesser les
législatives ces deux noms de lieux de
l'investiture qui pourra obtenir je
pense qu'il faut qu'il fasse attention
quand même c'est les investitures il va
aussi les obtenir par le sa capacité à
mouiller la chemise pour le collectif
quoi dans ce qui est génial c'est que
les équipes d' emmanuel macron en
coulisses à 10 et aux journalistes vous
allez voir edwards est vraiment hyper
mobilisés il a vraiment envie de jouer
un rôle crucial vous allez voir ça
c'était il ya un mois
il reste deux jours qu'il sait peut-être
un effet surprise qui s'est merci
beaucoup merci à tous d'avoir participé
à ce débat on vient de revoir la la
couverture de votre livre publié aux
éditions de l'archipel et mathieu
soupière l'autre c'est chez plon et
c'est 2022 la flambée populiste coécrit
avec
damien fleurot jeu